[Música]
Sean bienvenidos a un episodio más de
historia en France 24 Mi nombre es
Álvaro Cordero la política de seguridad
implantada por nayib bukele durante el
último año ha sido un motivo de críticas
y alabanzas hace tan solo unos días el
mandatario salvadoreño desplegó a 5000
militares en el municipio de Concepción
al norte del país tras el asesinato de
un policía por las pandillas su
metodología ha sido cuestionada por los
tintes autoritarios que desprende un
estado policial y por las violaciones a
los Derechos Humanos que denuncian
numerosas organizaciones internacionales
pero desde el ejecutivo salvadoreño
promocionan que ha puesto fin a décadas
de control de las pandillas y su
respaldo entre la población es alto Pero
cuál ha sido la relación histórica que
ha tenido El Salvador con la violencia
para llegar a este punto
El génesis de esta situación está en la
guerra civil que asoló al país entre
1979 y 1992 y que dejó más de 75.000
muertos y 15.000 desaparecidos El
problema es que cuando los las dos
partes alcanzaron la paz la estructura
Estatal estaba muy debilitada y el vacío
de poder era tan grande que fue ocupado
por bandas criminales que brindaban una
oportunidad y cierto prestigio en las
calles a jóvenes sin futuro y de
familias desestructuradas las dos
principales son la Mara Salvatrucha 13 y
la barrio 18 organizaciones criminales
rivales que comenzaron a parasitar el
estado y a penetrar en las calles la
economía y las instituciones del
Salvador sin mucha oposición durante la
década de 1990 hasta que se volvieron un
problema mayúsculo a principios de siglo
debido a su relación con el narcotráfico
y su elevada violencia así hablaba sobre
el asunto el expresidente Francisco
Flores
en diversos puntos del país
ahí cobran impuestos de guerra
venden drogas
corrompen menores
Asesinan y mantienen aterrorizadas a
muchas familias Su respuesta fue la
táctica de la mano dura pero a pesar del
aumento de las detenciones el poder de
las maras siguió aumentando desde las
cárceles sus líderes a pesar de
permanecer en prisión siguieron
dirigiendo estas organizaciones que
mantuvieron una guerra sin cuartel
contra el estado y entre ellas mismas El
problema era que aunque se detuviera a
miles la situación de marginación y de
falta de oportunidades en los barrios
más pobres empujaba a los jóvenes a
pertenecer a estos grupos y
probablemente a morir de forma prematura
por eso operaciones llamativas como la
siguiente servían de muy poco
se limpia bastante lo que es la
comunidad iberia ya que es una comunidad
donde hay bastante Pandilla de la de la
MS vamos a seguir trabajando en algunos
planes de prevención su crecimiento hizo
que la influencia de las maras llegaran
incluso a la política y que se
intentaran nuevas estrategias como
negociar beneficios carcelarios para sus
líderes a cambio de una reducción en el
número de asesinatos así lo hizo
Mauricio Funes en su gobierno entre 2009
y 2014 y otros muchos miembros de su
partido como nayib bukele durante la
alcaldía de San Salvador entre 2015 y
2018 y aunque la violencia bajó en estos
años no lo hizo por mucho tiempo
como podemos ver en este gráfico antes
del pacto con las maras había una
incidencia de 70 homicidios por cada
100.000 habitantes en El Salvador
después de ese pacto entre 2012 y 2013
la cantidad de homicidios se redujo
notablemente pero una vez que se rompió
el pacto con estos grupos criminales
subió hasta 103 homicidios por cada
100.000 habitantes convirtiendo al
Salvador en el país más peligroso de
todo el planeta después de ese de esa
cifra Durante los años siguientes y
especialmente tras la llegada de nayib
bukele estos datos fueron reduciéndose
progresivamente hasta que en 2022
alcanzó el
7,87,8 homicidios por cada 100.000
habitantes Pero cuál ha sido la
estrategia de nayib bukele para llegar
hasta esta cifra pues al principio esa
reducción se dio según han podido
esclarecer varios medios de comunicación
como el faro y agencias internacionales
por pactos secretos con estas
organizaciones lo que ocurre es que la
situación cambió tras el asesinato de 87
personas en un fin de semana en El
Salvador detrás de esta ola de violencia
que ocurrió en marzo de 2022 parece que
está una ruptura entre La tregua entre
las maras y nayib bukele y Su respuesta
fue una operación militar que detuvo a
decenas de miles de personas en apenas
unas semanas
a los que los tenemos colchonetas
durmiendo en el suelo fascinados con dos
tiempos de comida y es importante que
sepan que si se tratan de pasar de vivos
vamos a bajar de dos tiempos a cero
tiempos de comida y vamos a ver cuánto
tiempo dura estos métodos violan
numerosos derechos humanos pero han
contado con una gran popularidad debido
a que efectivamente han reducido la tasa
de homicidios en El Salvador hasta
niveles históricos y con ella han
reducido también el poder de las maras
más de un año después del inicio del
estado de excepción Es innegable que la
violencia Estatal Esta vez sí ha
terminado con buena parte de estas
organizaciones su espectacularidad le ha
brindado un gran una gran popularidad y
publicidad a bukele pero la historia nos
demuestra que estos métodos aunque a
veces parezcan efectivos en el corto
plazo también atentan contra personas
inocentes y en El Salvador ya se han
reportado miles de casos todo ello sin
contar con la violación a los derechos
constitucionales que se han producido en
este tiempo algo que hace temer que con
el pretexto de acabar con las maras
bukele aproveche también para terminar
con la democracia con esto concluimos si
quieren conocer más historias sigan
conectados a France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]